You and I both know that the title of
this video is a lie.
I'm never going to delete it,
but nonetheless,
you clicked on it.
On the odd chance I do delete it.
You get to be part of the lucky few that
gets to see this video before it
disappears into the void,
and that's what we're going to talk
about today.
That feeling of scarcity and
specifically how people market to that
scarcity to make you look at things,
want things and buy things.
Have you ever noticed how much
advertisers talk about limits and
urgency?
We live the thrill of beating the clock.
Any sized soft drinks for a dollar won't
stick around long.
Buy One,
get one free this Friday and Saturday,
only October.
Hurry in now to October savings end
soon.
Now,
why do advertisers do this?
Some of you may feel that this is merely
incidental.
All good things come to an end after
all,
but that isn't quite true.
Companies deliberately want to send you
the message that this,
this incredible deal won't be here for
long because the reason we want things,
the reason we buy things often has very
little to do with the product and
everything to do with how the ad makes
us feel and selling.
Scarcity is all about making you and I
feel like we've been given opportunity.
Opportunity is not the same as being
given a choice.
Opportunity is a choice,
but it has a special component.
It's a time bound choice.
It has to be seized.
It won't be there for long.
It forces action.
You can have this product at this
specially discounted rate,
but the deal ends this weekend.
It forces you to say yes or no to a deal
because inaction is a choice and it may
surprise you,
but this is different from our normal
behavior.
Think about when you're in a store.
Normally.
Usually when you pass up on a product,
you're not actually saying no to it.
You're just saying maybe later we do
this all the time.
We're procrastinators by nature and if
allowed will shop around for awhile
because the implication with most goods
and services is that they're going to
still be there when you come back,
but with limited time or limited
quantity sales,
the goal is to remove the option of
saying maybe a later to an object.
He'd forces action,
say yes and buy it or say no and kiss
this deal goodbye forever and this is a
fundamental change and can push you from
uncertainty to buying a product out of
fear that it will be gone if you come
back later and just how effective is
this form of marketing?
Well,
let's look at Amazon,
the largest distributor in store in the
world.
What does the most successful store do
you when it puts on huge sales,
it put scarcity marketing to work and
from two different angles.
Look at this.
This is not only a limited time sale and
it's not only a limited quantity sale,
it's both and when it's done,
it's done.
This one little web widget that tracks
how much of the product has moved and
tracks how much time has passed moves
product like crazy.
Take for instance,
this seller who during a four hour
lightning sales sold over 6,000
units when they normally would have sold
four to $500 in a given day.
That's a 1300 percent increase in sales
for taking 20 percent off the price and
putting it on the lightning page or to
put that in business.
So what does consumer psychology have to
say about this?
Well,
there's react in theory and there's
commodity react.
In theory developed by Jack Brown says
that when an individual's freedom to
engage in a specific behavior is
threatened,
the threatened behavior becomes more
attractive.
This is why,
for instance,
when politicians mentioned gun control
ammunition flies off the shelves because
gun owners are worried about their
future ability to buy it.
It's also why this video title is so
provocative because I'm threatening to
take it away from you.
The other theory we're going to explore
is commodity theory.
This idea developed by brock and fromkin
suggests that goods which appeared to be
scarce are considered to be more
valuable.
This is the idea behind diamonds which
are actually not rare at all,
but due to a very tightly controlled
supply have artificially sustain the
high price point.
So when marketing companies tell you
that something isn't,
soon,
they're trying to artificially restrict
the supply to raise the value in your
mind.
Now,
I think a mixture of both of these
theories come into play in shaping how
we respond to perceived scarcity,
but either way,
scarcity
plays on our ancient impulses to take
advantage of limited resources.
And this idea hits particularly close to
home for me because as some of you know,
I work a sales job selling houses as my
main nine to five job and when we run
promotionals,
we do it to generate this exact kind of
feeling I've been talking about.
Because when people want to take their
time and mull over a decision,
it can lead them to buying nothing at
all.
So to get a positional advantage,
we run promos periodically to get the
leverage to say enough thinking.
It's time to make a decision.
I mean,
you do want to take advantage of this
big sale,
don't you?
In reality,
is there any reason the house houses
should be less expensive that month?
No,
but we want people to think there is
because it creates urgency.
Our reaction to scarcity is a powerful
force in advertising and marketing.
It plays on one of our most fundamental
instincts to not miss out on
opportunity,
and this bias is exploited constantly by
businesses who use advertising and
marketing tactics to create artificial
scarcity.
So just as a rule of thumb,
if you live in a developed country where
abundance is the norm,
rather than the exception,
you can begin to safely make the
assumption that if someone is telling
you supplies are low,
they're probably trying to sell you
something.